he was one of the rising stars in gaza's
media world and the eldest son of
alzer's Gaza bureau chief W ALU one of
the most well-known journalists in
Palestine like he has done every day for
the past three months Hamza Al had gone
out to document the aftermath of an
Israeli attack in sou Gaza but the
27-year-old journalist never returned to
file his
report I'm bidding farewell today what
else can I say say may God the almighty
give us strength give us Comfort give us
patience may God the almighty give us
the strength to carry on for the sake of
Hamza and for the sake of all those
killed I say we will remain faithful
this isn't the first time while Al has
suffered such a loss in October his wife
other son daughter and Grandson were all
killed in an Israeli strike on a house
and last month he was injured in an
Israeli attack that killed his colleague
Samir Abu
Daka for hamza's friends his death is a
tragedy they can't comprehend I don't
want to cry but I'm reporting this right
now because I know that if if Hamza was
here he wanted me to report and he
wanted all of our his colleagues to
report and to continue reporting and I'm
so proud of Hamza and everything he did
and everything he reported Hamza had a
close Bor with his father whom he walked
with in the field he was his first uh
born his eldest son um he was the one he
relied on he wanted him Always by his
side he was so proud that Hamza studied
um journalism AFP journalist Mustafa
thoraya was also killed in the same
Israeli strike that targeted hamza's
car at least 10 journalists have been
killed since Israel's war on Gaza
started in early October
hamza's life might have been cut short
but his father and friends say they will
continue to report on Israel's war on
Gaza no matter the
consequences Hamza Muhammad Al
jaaz make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer